we will find out how this election turns
out pretty soon
before we get into the mailbag there are
some election updates right now we found
out there will be
a hand recount in the state of georgia
you'll remember on election night trump
was winning georgia
significantly and then you know just
magically in the middle of the night all
those biden votes came in
so here we have georgia secretary of
state brad raffensberger what a name
announcing there will be a by-hand
recount in every
county in georgia the next step in the
current election process
is getting the final county
certifications in we'll then move to the
risk limiting audit
or rla at 1 pm today
i will make the official designation of
which race will be the subject of the
rla
at that time i will designate that the
roa
will be the presidential race with the
margin being so close
it will require a full by hand recount
in each county this will help build
confidence
it will be an audit a recount and a
re-canvas
all at once it will be a heavy lift
but we will work with the counties to
get this done in time
for our state certification many of
these workers will be working plenty of
overtime
we have all worked hard to bring fair
and accurate counts to assure
that the will of the voters is reflected
in the final count
and that every voter will have
confidence in the outcome
wherever whether they're candidate won
or lost
so you heard that term rla rla refers to
risk
limiting audit it's not enough to count
the votes again
if you've got fraudulent votes in there
and you recount the fraudulent votes you
haven't accomplished anything
there are votes in there that maybe
weren't sent in by the people
who said that they were sending them in
there are votes in there that maybe were
not sent in by people who i don't know
are alive there are votes maybe in there
that were sent
in by people who aren't people you know
maybe they're the family's beloved pet
or something
we've heard a few stories about that
during this election season we just
don't know
so it's not enough to recount you've got
to audit those votes
usually you're going to hear political
geniuses tell you
that recounts don't matter that much
yeah sure they find fraud there's always
fraud but it's not going to shift the
vote that much
that may be true but we have never had
widespread unsolicited mail-in ballots
we're now talking
about what that the numbers that the
media are putting out are 74 million
votes for biden
71 72 million votes for trump
those numbers are unprecedented now
maybe it's because of huge voter turnout
maybe it's because there's fraud maybe
there was huge voter turnout but some of
those votes were not eligible we don't
know and so you've got to audit
that vote it's not just happening in
georgia we're getting great stories
coming out
of arizona now as well joe biden's lead
in arizona remember arizona was called
for biden
on election night by the ostensibly
conservative network
now who knows how conservative they are
exactly if they're the first ones
calling arizona for biden
but the trump team has been very
confident from the beginning we are
going to do very very well
in arizona it turns out it looks like
that's correct
joe biden's lead in arizona has now
shrunk below 13 000
after maricopa county dropped some more
ballots
according to data orbital the county's
latest report includes 50
almost 5300 votes 56.4 percent going to
trump
41.8 percent going to biden pinault
county also posted some more ballots on
tuesday
shows trump taking 63.3 percent of the
almost 1 000 ballots counted there
there remain forty six thousand seven
hundred ballots
in arizona twenty two thousand four
hundred of them come from maricopa
county maricopa is
is pretty decidedly for trump now
president trump needs to take 64
in those remaining ballots in order to
win arizona
that's a high number but it is not
outside the realm of possibility
all pretty good news there and that's
why cnn
is absolutely freaking out we are being
told now
that if president trump does not concede
never mind the recounts never mind the
hand recount
georgia recounts counts still going on
in arizona
the investigation is going on in
philadelphia never mind all that trump's
got to concede
these demagogues tell us because
otherwise
trump will compromise american national
security
yes or no are the actions that the
president is taking now
putting this country in danger
clearly it's not great for our democracy
okay fair uh
let's put some teeth on that if we can
for a moment because
there are sitting members of congress
who were around in their positions at
the time of 9 11.
and the 911 commission report
specifically cited the shortened
transition
after the 2000 election for having an
impact on national security i'm quoting
here
it hampered the new administration in
identifying recruiting
clear clearing and obtaining senate
confirmation of key appointees
the fact is we have experience for how
shortened transitions make a difference
in national security
why are we hearing from republicans
uh about that granting that potential
danger
yeah why why are these republicans doing
that i mean it's just so awful that
they're compromising national security
i don't remember cnn raising this this
concern
when al gore was dragging the 2000
election out for 38 days based on
nothing by the way based on
absolutely nothing compared to what
we've got now i guess if democrats were
so concerned about this maybe
they should not have refused to allow
republican poll watchers in philadelphia
because if they if they didn't do that
if they didn't illegally
refuse to allow republican poll watchers
and ignore a court order
then maybe we wouldn't have to drag this
out so long maybe they shouldn't have
forced this widespread unsolicited
mail-in ballots
which are vulnerable to fraud maybe they
shouldn't have done that but they did so
unfortunately we're not going to
unilaterally disarm democrats
if you enjoyed that video and i would
hope that you did
please be sure to hit the subscribe
button so that all of the befuddled
radicals
wading through the wasteland of youtube
knows
where they can get the truth thanks